I put this out earlier today and it says
how to encourage marriage by fixing
divorce in five simple steps
number one eliminate alimony okay
by the way none of this is ever going to
happen not in our lifetime
the only way to get these things is to
go somewhere where it already exists
there are places in the world that don't
hate men that aren't hostile where you
can go
get married you call whatever you want
get married have a family you know
whatever it happens to be and you don't
you don't have these groups but in the
west and most western places so you want
to fix marriage you want to encourage
guys to sign up for marriage daily wire
and all the guys in that Clan or crew
this is how you do it you you fix it by
fixing the divorce laws eliminate
alimony if women are so strong and
independent today and don't need no man
and a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle you've all heard the
sound bites we hear it all the time
women are a lot going on about it all
the time on social media get rid of
alimony why do they need it it shouldn't
exist you know if you're still strong
and independent stand on your own two
feet after you get divorced pay your own
[__] and look after yourself you're a
grown-ass adult but no in many places in
the west you get divorced you're paying
alimony sometimes not for a fixed period
of time you're paying it for a lifetime
you're paying to support somebody else
that you're not married to anymore
you're not being intimate with you're
you're not enjoying intimacy or sexual
benefits from you're actually paying
them money and some other dude is
banging them you know it doesn't make
any sense right why do you have to
maintain their lifestyle into perpetuity
just because they married you now
some people you know rightly will say
something like well Rich you know like
what would you say to your daughter
would you tell her not to get married
it's a different conversation if you
have a daughter totally different
conversation
tell her to get married of course like
why would you it's a great freaking deal
if you love your child and she can find
a guy that's got his life sorted why not
tell her to get married there's no
downside it's all upside it's low risk
High reward for for women it's high risk
low reward for men so again the first
thing eliminate alimony
let me make this a little bit bigger
second thing default 50 50 custody why
are we living in a world where men have
to fight for custody why does it make
any sense
most fathers are more than capable and
in fact the statistics say they're
better at it than women at raising
children and turning them turning them
into productive useful members of
society I wouldn't argue that women are
better at it when the children are
smaller they need the nurturing they
need the mother they need the breast
milk they need all that stuff like women
are better at that phase of life but to
remove a man from his child's life which
women are incentivized to do because
when they do it they also get child
support and control by the way okay they
want to make medical decisions
unilaterally without your uh input
mandatory DNA testing or paternity
testing as it's called
because
it's nearly impossible to establish
the rates of which paternity fraud
exists
the word fraud is a part of paternity
fraud because it relies on one party
being deceptive to the other women have
with 100 percent assurance that when
they are pregnant and they birth a child
it is theirs they know it because they
carried it and they pushed it through
their body so there's no confusion which
is fine but men have some uncertainty in
that area it's entirely possible and it
happens where women get impregnated by
somebody else and then they point to
that guy who could be the husband he may
not be the husband at that time and says
that's the father you're the father this
is yours you stand up and man up now
going back to the notion that we don't
know what the actual rates happen to be
I came across some data I was doing some
research when I was writing my first
edition of the book
and it mostly comes from the medical
establishment and from school
assignments believe it or not
if you ask women out there if they could
honestly take a survey and state whether
or not the father or the person that has
been playing the role of the dad to
their children is a real father and get
an honest answer you're not going to get
it because if they
say that they're that the guy is not the
father then that exposes them to
potential harm that exposes them to
shame there's a lot of consequences the
consequences are much much higher for
women so
it's understandable as to why they would
be deceptive and lie about the paternity
of the child or pretend like I don't
know or I'm pretty sure it's him it's
got to be him it's got his eyebrows or
whatever
um
it's been revealed a number of times uh
in medical establishment so as an
example without going through all of
them uh if you've got a sick child that
has a disease they do blood Labs on the
child they do they then do blood Labs on
the parents to try to establish the
genome and potential remedies or if they
need to I don't know the kids got bone
cancer or something like that is there
they need a kidney you know one of the
parents say a donor and then the medical
establishment then discovers oh wait
hold on a second yeah that's the mom but
the DNA has no association to the father
that's not the father
now depending on where they live
they don't always disclose it to the
father they'll have a conversation with
a mom and say you know are you sure that
he's the dad because the blood labs are
you know the results from the testing
say that he's not the father and you
know at that time they're in a private
room with the medical professional and
her and they might have a conversation
like well I'm not entirely certain but
maybe he's not it there was another guy
around the same time and then maybe the
medical you know professional says well
we don't have to disclose it here in
this state or Province but just so you
know right
um the medical establishment has shown
somewhere between 10 to 15 percent of
the time when they're doing these uh
studies you know on the blood and the
kids and the sickness and all this sort
of stuff the guy that's been acting as a
dad is not the dad
um School assignments have shown the
numbers to be high as well to say that's
across the board that 25 or 20 percent
of the time uh there's paternity fraud
would be an unfair statement but it
exists that's the problem the fact that
it exists the fact that it is a
potential to exist is a problem for men
men do not want to raid the sea raise
the seed of another man it's why most
single moms are repulsive to guys and
they don't want to get involved with
them and they get turned off and will
have been expressed frustration and this
sort of stuff online when they're trying
to settle down and you know find a guy
and get right and all that sort of stuff
um you know when they've got kids in tow
from a prior type of relationship so I
think that mandatory DNA testing at the
point at the hospital when the child's
born uh being done uh makes marriage and
having kids that much more attractive
because it's one of the legitimate
grievances that men have expressed today
is paternity fraud exists cuckold
re-exists and it's at a rate that is
unknown but higher than what most uh
people out there will hold out to the
public it it's it's real it's a real
problem and the fifth one is uh issuing
child support to what the child actually
needs
um
again lots of conversations on this in
the past there's been lots of guys who
have stated look you know when I was
married
um my cost to cover swimming lessons and
extracurriculars and after school care
and meals and clothing and all this sort
of stuff about a thousand bucks a month
right and you know your dad you're happy
to pay it it's your kid you want to look
after them but when you get divorced and
they and then the government gets
involved and they start punching numbers
into their tables this is where [__]
starts getting interesting they start
basing it on your income and a
percentage of your income the
discrepancy between her income and your
income and it's like child support
doesn't get distributed based on what is
required for the child to live in that
other household it's based on their
tables and there's lots of dads that
have found well when I was married it
was costing me about a thousand bucks a
month you know recover all this but now
that they've punched numbers in a table
that number goes up to 3 217 dollars and
18 cents a month and they're like
where's this money going and it's going
to our Handbags and shoes not to the
kids right so you want to fix marriage
you want to encourage marriage you're
going to fix it by fixing things in
divorce and I didn't write this saying
that this is a remedy and this will get
adopted and be used to fix things I
wrote it knowing full [__] well that
it's never going to happen in my
lifetime I wrote it because these are
the things that are required and all of
these things If you eliminate alimony If
you eliminate default 50 50 custody If
you eliminate the division of assets If
you eliminate mandatory paternity tests
If you eliminate child support for what
the child actually needs women are going
to lose their [__] guys aren't going to
change these laws there's no way guys
can get together men's rights activists
none of these groups getting together to
like petition go to Capitol Hill and say
anything will ever fix any of these
things it's never ever going to happen
the charge for these changes needs to
come from women and why would women
change these things if it benefits them
so greatly think about it why if your
benefit if you've got such a strong
Advantage entering into a marriage
contract why would you change any of the
things that benefit you so greatly that
make it so low risk and high reward to
get married why would you change any of
those things that's why when all of
these pink pill chicks online they're
all yeah marriage isn't fair for fathers
and why do you think they're not getting
they butt heads with like the track cons
it's like ladies ladies if you're
serious if you really give a [__] about
men and want them to marry you and you
want to have more marriages you want to
fix the problem get the gals together in
the thousands and tens of thousands even
better hundreds of thousands and go and
March on Capitol Hill policy makers
bureaucrats and tell them shit's not
fair men aren't marrying us we want to
change these things over here that I've
just mentioned it's never going to
happen ever never ever ever it's far
better and easier for them to create
outrage on social media and Twitter to
get eyeballs and Views and follows and
dorks in their comments going yeah you
go girly
not gonna happen ever
okay but that's what it takes to run to
remedy it are there things that you can
do can you vet women better yeah don't
you know don't deal with women that have
red flags all all the stuff that I talk
about in my book I mean I cover all of
it from a bunch of different angles in
my book you do all those things you got
a better chance of having success but at
the end of the day going somewhere where
men aren't hated where they're treated
fairly where all of these things already
exist which do in many parts of the
world you know where there's
um cultural and religious values that
subscribe to these uh Notions and you
know people message me all the time like
yo Rich Islam's got it sorted out man
like like the unplugged Alpha is
basically Islam it's like cool if that's
what it is go there you know there's
there's remedies to it I'm not saying
don't have kids I'm not saying uh don't
deal with women I'm not saying
um
you know don't date women or any of
those things I'm saying do it if you
want but walk into it with your eyes
wide open because it's a slaughterhouse
there's a lot of sharp objects in there
that can hurt you and most guys get hurt
the vast majority of guys uh do get hurt
pretty badly and some get destroyed and
there's a very large percentage versus
women I think the number's something
like 10 times higher if not more that
men that self-delete after a divorce
women aren't self-deleting after divorce
it's men it's men that are doing it in
much much larger numbers but again like
I said earlier nobody cares about men
nobody gives a [__] about men we pretend
like we care about men we you know we
you know we pretend like there's men's
rights and there's honey badgers and
men's rights activists and women pink
pill Chicks online they're basically
saying the same [__] that men have been
saying for decades like they give a [__]
about men
um it just it just doesn't exist so
you know to the point of well what do
you do you do what's best for you you
know you do what you think is right for
you and if you want to test it out if
you want to march in a slaughterhouse if
you want to get into a marriage if you
want to take on a woman that's shared
her body with 40 50 guys 10 guys even it
doesn't matter do it but at least do it
knowing what you're getting into uh walk
into it enlightened I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out